[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hey there, iOS developers.
If you watched our
previous quick tip,
you learned that you don't have
to give up your fancy UI View
Animations just because
you're using constraints.
The trick is that, instead
of directly animating
your views'
positions themselves,
you can animate their
constraints either by animating
the constant associated
with those constraints,
or by enabling and disabling
completely different sets
of constraints to make your
views do different things,
and then calling
layout, if needed,
within the animation block.
But this came with a
couple of extra quick tips
from one of Google's very own
engineers, Jessica Horowitz.
Jessica is an engineer working
on some cool new native iOS
search features.
And she had a few notes on
how you could best optimize
your constraint animation.
So in our previous
video, you'll recall
that I could make
these three views
switch from being
left-aligned to right-aligned
simply by removing
and then adding
different sets of constraints.
It turns out, however, that
adding and removing constraints
from your layout requires
quite a bit of work
from the auto layout engine and
can be pretty CPU intensive.
And as some folks around
here are fond of saying,
performance matters.
Ah!
Don't do that.
Shoo.
So instead of
enabling and disabling
different sets of
constraints, Jessica
recommends you enable all the
constraints at design time.
Let me show you.
So here, I'm going back
into Interface Builder.
And I'm going to
enable the constraints
that both left align and
right align my views.
Of course, when
you do that, Xcode
will once again
complain that you
have conflicting constraints.
But don't freak out.
Are you freaking out?
Stop it.
Instead, go into
your inspector here,
and change the priorities
of your constraints.
In my example, I'm
going to change
the priorities of
the ones I want
Xcode to ignore for now to 1.
And I'll change the
priorities of the ones
I want to keep to 999.
Now, we can go
back into our code.
And instead of
enabling or disabling
our two sets of constraints, we
can just change the priorities
back and forth
between 999 and 1,
a little something like this.
I have the same
behavior as before.
But this kind of
priority chaining
is much more efficient
than enabling and disabling
constraints entirely.
By the way, in case
you're wondering
why I had to change my high
priority constraints to 999
instead of leaving them at
the default value of 1,000,
it's because iOS
interprets constraints
set at 1,000 as
required constraints,
meaning that I can't set
them later to anything lower.
Setting it to 999 means
it'll probably take priority,
but it's also optional.
So I'm able to
lower it later on.
Now, in addition, Jessica
had a second tip for you.
You'll notice that
in my samples I've
been calling layout if
needed on self.view right
there in the view controller.
Now, in many cases, particularly
little examples like this,
it'll work just fine.
But in some more complex
cases, it will not.
Let's take a look at
this example here.
You can see I have
a container view
controller-- this
red and blue thing--
placed inside another
view controller, where
I've added these gray bars
here at the top and the bottom.
Now, watch what happens when
I animate a few constraints
within the container view
controller and then call
self.view.layoutifneeded.
You can see that this container
itself animates smoothly.
But these bars at the top
and bottom, as well as
the placement of the container
pops, which kind of ruins
that whole smooth transition
look I was going for.
So the trick here, and our
second quick tip of the day,
is that you really
need to call layout
if needed on the deepest
view whose size or position
won't be affected by the
constraints you're animating.
So in this example,
I found that I
was able to get a smooth
animation by calling layout
if needed not on my
view controller's view
but on my view controller's
view's super view's super view.
So that's much better.
But how did I figure that out?
Well, I would love
to tell you it's
because I logically
analyzed my view's hierarchy
and calculated the
appropriate level from there.
But honestly, I just kept
adding super views until I
got something that worked.
Trial and error, it's great.
So that said, you could
always break out the big guns
and call layout if needed
on your view's window--
this thing here--
which basically
forces auto layout
to recalculate
your entire hierarchy.
But that, as you can imagine,
gets pretty expensive
and is probably
excessive in most cases.
Remember, perf matters.
Oh.
Go away.
You've got your own show.
Leave mine alone.
So thank you, once again,
to Jessica for the tips.
Jessica, I know you work here,
but you've totally earned
yourself a Google T-shirt too.
What about you?
Got a quick tip?
Send it to me at
this address here,
and you can be
just like Jessica.
Well, I mean, in the fact
that you'll get a T-shirt.
I can't guarantee
you'll get to be
an engineer here or anything.
But you know, we are hiring.
Just saying.
So thanks, once
again, for watching.
And I will see you
soon on Route 85.
[MUSIC PLAYING]